[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson we're glad to see you it's only
monday but we're going to try and cram
the nutritional content of an entire
week of shows into the next hour we've
got governor ron desantis on new reports
that the white house is secretly flying
illegal aliens into the state of florida
because immigration is not about
politics then we've got dave portnoy of
barstool sports who is waging one of the
great battles of all time against
repulsive slurs from legacy media
outlets that hate him they're trying to
destroy him he is unbowed
then we've got congresswoman marjorie
taylor greene who is one of the only
lawmakers who was bothered to visit the
january 6th defendants who are rotting
in the dc jail
she'll tell us what she just saw there
we want to start tonight with joe biden
the isolated and deeply unpopular
president of the united states at this
point pretty much no one likes joe biden
or will admit it the latest you at usa
today poll has biden at a terrifying 38
job approval rating biden's been in
office less than a year and already
two-thirds of voters do not want him to
run again
how unpopular is joe biden as of tonight
let's put it this way he's only 10
points above the single most despised
person in the united states which is his
own vice president
jeffrey ebstein now has more admirers
than kamala harris does and that is the
territory that joe biden now occupies
so it's genuinely bad and it has
political effects as we saw last week
the question is why is this happening
why are people so dissatisfied all of a
sudden with joe biden
well the obvious answer is you're going
to hear a lot of people say this joe
biden is senile and ineffective
but if you think about it that's not
true it can't really be true because
voters knew perfectly well all along
that biden was dottering they knew that
when they elected him it was obvious
even then in fact it was part of his
appeal biden was too slow to be
threatening to anyone this was not a guy
who was going to be making a lot of
sudden moves if you secretly wished it
was still 1985 joe biden was your man
because he was under the impression that
it actually was
so no senility is not joe biden's main
problem joe biden's problem is weakness
biden is afraid
you see it every time you look at him
he's overwhelmed he's off balance and
that's why he's so often snappy and
aggressive because underneath it all he
feels anxious
biden isn't always sure where he is or
what's happening around him
so a man like that cannot possibly lead
a country this complex but the problem
is his weakness makes him a target for
predators ideologues like susan rice or
barack obama can take a man like that
hostage and make him read their scripts
that's exactly what is happening and you
saw it so clearly last week our own
peter ducey asked biden about the white
house plan to pay reparations to illegal
aliens up to almost half a million
dollars per person
so the very idea of an administration
doing that under any circumstances is
completely deranged what's interesting
is that joe biden who's not ideological
he's emotional biden understood that
immediately and so he responded when
asked the way that any normal person
would he said effectively what the hell
are you talking about that's crazy watch
there were reports that were surfacing
that your administration is planning to
pay
illegal immigrants who are separated
from their families at the border
up to 450 000 each possibly a million
dollars per family
do you think that that might incentivize
more people to come over illegally if
you guys keep sending that garbage out
yeah
but it's not true so this is a garbage
report
well yeah biden was right reparations
for illegals that is garbage and most
people think it a new poll by the
trafalgar group shows that fully
two-thirds of the country that's a
majority of democrats as well as of
course the majority of republicans
believe that idea is nuts because it
obviously is nuts paying people to break
our laws were you crazy that would
destroy the country obviously
now whatever you think of biden he's
been in politics for more than 50 years
and at this point if nothing else he's
got a pretty good gut sense of these
things so the second he heard that idea
the second peter ducey presented it to
him he was against it on instinct
unfortunately joe biden is no longer in
charge he no longer makes meaningful
decisions the ideologues are in charge
the obama people are in charge that's
the point that's what we're watching
so after that moment they hauled joe
biden before the central committee they
gave him a good re-education and the
next thing you know biden is out there
dutifully repeating their lunatic
slogans watch this
if in fact because of the the outrageous
behavior the last administration
you coming across the border whether it
was legal or illegal and you lost your
child
you lost your child it's gone
you deserve some kind of compensation no
matter what the circumstance what that
will be i have no idea i have no idea
you see that
the narrowed eyes the finger point the
jabbing in your face notice how angry
biden looks in that clip
this is not a man who's in control not
of his own emotions obviously but also
not of the administration he supposedly
runs the ideologues are in control and
that is a huge problem for the rest of
us
it's a problem because ideologues have
no interest in the lives of actual human
beings ideologues care only about their
theories about the bright new future
they are building human beings are just
speed bumps on the way to utopia
so not surprisingly when ideologues take
over a society any society in any
country at any point throughout history
life always gets much worse for most
people borders fall crime rises schools
collapse inflation gets out of control
suddenly there are drug addicts living
in tent cities in your neighborhood
screaming at your kids as you walk by
quality of life falls off a cliff
it's intolerable for most people
but the ideologues don't care because
they're completely focused on the shiny
new society they're constructing nothing
else matters perfection is always just
around the corner as soon as we get rid
of all these white men everything will
be great
they say that and they really believe it
meanwhile inevitably the actual physical
world around them the world that the
rest of us inhabit day-to-day crumbles
at high speed and you're seeing it now
everywhere
just today in the face of skyrocketing
energy prices the white house announced
it may shut down yet another pipeline
first it was keystone xl that happened
immediately this time the byte
administration like to close what's
called the line 5 pipeline you may not
have heard of that but it's vital to
this country the pipeline moves more
than half a million barrels of
desperately needed energy every day from
canada to michigan
shut that down
wait to see what happens to gas prices
they're already at record highs so if
you're not rich this is going to make
your life much worse and everyone knows
it
so no normal administration would even
consider doing something like this at a
moment like this shutting down a
pipeline in the middle of an energy
crisis no it's too destructive
but here's the thing from an ideologue's
perspective destruction is the whole
point
burn down wendy's loot macy's defund the
police close the school shut down the
energy grid tear it all down
scrape the pad so we can put up
something new and perfect
as they often put it build back better
the problem with thinking like this
there are many problems but the core
problem is that you tend to ignore the
suffering of the people who still live
in your country pre-utopia
you don't care about them and they know
you don't care about them
that dynamic is a huge problem it makes
societies particularly supposedly
democratic societies very volatile
wise leaders understand it so they are
very careful to pretend that they care
but not childish ideologues childless
ideologues just laugh in the face of
your suffering
here's jennifer granholm for example our
new energy secretary snickering about
rising gas prices
what is the grand home plan to increase
oil production in america
oh my god
that is hilarious wood that i had the
magic wand on this
doing something to save middle-class
americans from rising energy prices
quote that is hilarious says the energy
secretary
you can just imagine louis xvi talking
like this right before the french
revolution
it does make you wonder how long this
can continue hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else